With the core concepts of networking within Unreal now covered,
it's time we look at how our data gets from the server to the client,
namely the actor replication flow.
In terms of the replication flow,
the bulk of the work takes place in the server replicate actors function of the net driver.
This is the function where the server determines what is relevant to each client.
Once all actors have been gathered for each client,
the server will then replicate components and their data,
as well as data within the actors directly that has changed since the last update.
When it comes to replication, the actor class provides key replication framework functions
and variables that control how and when an actor is replicated across the network.
The functions and properties listed here are the key ones that we really should take note of,
so let's cover each one and see what they do.
Firstly we've got the net update frequency which we covered earlier.
This determines how often an actor replicates.
Next we've got the pre-replication function inside of actor,
and this is called before any replication actually takes place.
From there we've got the be only relevant to owner bool,
and setting this to true means we only replicate down to our owning client.
Next we've got the is relevancy owner for function inside the actor.
So if we are only relevant to our owning client,
we fall into the is relevancy owner for function
to bind onto any custom relevancy logic we may have set up.
Lastly we've got the is net relevant for function inside of actor.
So if we're not only relevant to our owner,
we're going to fall into this backup is net relevant for function
to see if there's any custom logic here.
With those functions and properties in mind,
we can now take a look at the high level flow of the replication process.
Firstly we loop over all actively replicated actors.
By this we mean we refer to any actors that have the be replicates flag set to true.
From there we determine if this actor is initially dormant.
If it comes back as dormant, we can just ignore it.
Next we determine if this actor needs to update by checking the net update frequency value.
So if it replicated too recently, we can ignore this one as well.
Next we check if the actor is only relevant to the owner falling into the previously mentioned
is relevancy owner for function.
If this returns true, then we add this actor to the list of actors owned by the connection.
If it returns false, we just ignore it.
Next we call the pre replication function,
and this function allows developers to decide if properties within the actor want to replicate to that given connection.
It's worth noting that if you want to utilize this functionality,
you must use the do rep lifetime active override macro in your get lifetime replicated props function.
If this actor passes all of these tests,
we're going to add it to a list of actors that we're going to consider for this particular update.
So now that we've built a list of actors that we want to replicate,
we need to see if we can replicate them.
Firstly, we determine if the actor is dormant.
If it's not, we then see if it has an actor channel open yet.
The actor channel essentially being a connection between the server and the client representation.
If the actor channel is not open yet,
we need to check if it's because the client has yet to load into the level that the actor resides in.
If the client hasn't loaded that level, we're just going to skip this actor.
Next, we determine if the actor is relevant to this connection by calling the is net relevant for function.
If it's not relevant, then this actor will be skipped.
If we pass all of these checks, we can assume this actor is now owned by this connection and can be free to replicate it.
With our list of actors that are relevant to this connection, we perform the following steps.
First, we sort the actor by priority, and then for each of those sorted actors,
we check that the connection hasn't loaded the level that this actor is in yet.
If there's an actor channel open, we close it.
Every second, we determine if this actor is relevant for this connection by calling its is net relevant for function.
If it's not relevant for five seconds, then we close the channel entirely.
If the actor is relevant and we don't have an actor channel for it, we'll open one.
When dealing with a saturated connection, we fall into a deferred update cycle of sorts.
We loop through the remaining actors in the list and assess how long they've been relevant or irrelevant for.
If they've been relevant for less than a second, we forcibly push an update into the next tick.
We can't possibly have drifted too far out of sync from the server in that time.
If they've been relevant for more than a second, we call the is net relevant for
to determine if we do need to push an update into the next tick at all.
For any actors that pass all of these checks, the actor is replicated to the connection
using the U channel replicate actor function.
We started in the server replicate actors function in the net driver,
and we've now covered how we decide what actors will be replicated to a connection.
It's time now that we look at how we replicate actors through that connection.
We start with the replicate actor function inside U channel.
This function is responsible for replicating an actor and all of its components to that connection.
With this, there is also a flow that we can take a look at, but don't worry,
it is much more simple than the previous ones.
Firstly, we determine if this is the first update since this actor channel was opened,
and if so, we serialize any specific information that is needed.
Next, we determine if the connection owns the actor in question.
If it's not owned and the actor's role is autonomous proxy,
then the role will be downgraded to simulated proxy.
Next, we replicate any changed properties within the actor,
and then we replicate any changed properties within the actor's components.
Finally, for any deleted components, we're going to send a special delete command.